[Music]
I have some new fun stuff from an
episode of trash Tuesday with your girl
Esther
or I have Bobby Lee in a room full of
Asians let's do trash Tuesday I'm okay
I'm starting to OD on Bobby I got you so
am I um you know who else was almost
oding Bobby
um
so here you go let's trash Tuesday your
girl Esther doesn't talks you've been
talking more since you criticized her
Marsh
I got I actually have a very like almost
too soon to Share story stop with the
energy
you're too fast-paced yeah you gotta
really like it's too much too quickly
Jesus Christ did you find some old
Quaaludes when you're emptying out your
grandfather's closet before the funeral
you know what nobody's ever said to
Esther okay all right all right calm
down start from the beginning
but I got you know you know what
someone's never said to her either
you're Jewish I couldn't tell
of me and my friends kicked out of a
nice hotel in Italy she got her and her
friends kicked out of a nice hotel in
Italy
nothing told you Carlos like it was you
are watching the news too loud bombing
everyone out wait that's you're just
following after Bobby's Footsteps in
again oh God and Esther you're gonna
watch it again Esther you're gonna watch
this clip because we know you watch
these clips sorry first no problems it's
good no it's just we're trying to escape
Bobby and it's still Bobby it's all
Bobby it's all Bobby even no matter what
we do
um and Esther watches these clips
because she Googles herself and we know
that and that's fine I do it too
sometimes but
um but Esther when you watch this I'm
gonna I'm gonna tell you this right now
and this is the most important thing
okay I think out of the three we like
you the most
please don't let khalila [ __ ] your dog
yeah please that's all I ask I see I
have a picture viewing your dog behind
you and I want to make sure some [ __ ] it
thank you he's been banned from a couple
hotels in Hawaii Carlos is going to
still it's pronounced Hawaii to the
locals Dave from you know there was
beautiful
a piano music being played and I was
drawn to it we were sitting in this
Lounge in this beautiful bar and the
multi coast and in a really nice hotel
and
um The Pianist had like taken a break
and then my friend's sister went and sat
down I would never say this to anybody
but maybe do like a little bit of
cocaine
like a little bit it's a tiny bit like a
little bit and she started playing My
Heart Will Go On It was so beautiful I
couldn't help but like get up and start
doing some
balletic movement oh my God you're
insufferable yeah if you got up in an
Italian Villa and started doing
interpretive dance you are the problem
no matter what happens after this point
yeah just [ __ ] smoke a cigarette and
drink your espresso and shut up
and maybe take your cigarette on the
balcony
you know we start off with you know like
something healthy like you know a ball
of chocolate a cup of milk a cup of
cream have a cup of cream
then we go out we go to work for like
one half hour two half hour
I thought it was and we all stay thin
because of olive oil going great like I
thought I was killing and I was just
starting to really feel myself so you
were drunken on drugs it's what it seems
like yeah it sounds like you were
drunken on drugs and all of a sudden
this Italian man in a suit marches over
and he was so mean he goes too much
ouch yeah because you went to a foreign
country and you started doing some
[ __ ] American hoe [ __ ] what do you
think's gonna happen yeah I'm sorry
[ __ ] acting like a buffoon Jesus
Christ even the dogs over there have
you've seen lady in the [ __ ]
so I'm in like the oldest city in
civilizations history right and like I
started like jumping around and like you
know making it all about me and then I
was wondering why everybody was mad so I
went to Mecca and I started twerking and
like they gave me so much attitude I was
in I was in Mecca I was doing the Hajj
and a Megan the stallion song came on
clothing store not
another merch
sudden thought [ __ ] starts playing yeah
laughs
so it's twerking like [ __ ] She-Hulk
[Laughter]
it's like not that mean Esther's always
oh my
God I mean I would but come on oh God
yeah and like I mean I would because
she's probably good let's be honest here
we give credit where credit is done yeah
this is probably a [ __ ] but also yeah
uh it's like no Annie um but in a
foreign country a man is also she's
fully feeling herself these [ __ ] all
of them think they could get away with
murder like all the time that's the one
thing they all have in common right
every time you hear their stories it's
about how they did something [ __ ] up
and how funny it is that they made
someone's life worse because of it
she's the freaking Prima ballerina at
this point I'll just never forget these
this finger movie
why is this
funny
it's not oh it's not Royce I think
that's what you're is this what is this
what women laugh at
I'm honest because a lot of women go the
[ __ ] I don't watch The View these are
three women that you know what they say
a lot I can't be friends with girls all
my friends are guys
oh yeah the [ __ ] hot dog meme yep
look at this or something when he did it
look again look I want to be clear here
I would
yes of course but also with the Herman
Munster boots what's going on
huh really
yeah
yeah exactly I would but like you said
only because you know she probably just
goes demon oh my God she probably sucks
sucks to come out of your balls you
don't even get a chance to come they
Chuck it's directly out like she's
siphoning gasoline during Katrina she
made Kurt Metzger's dick hard and he's
always on cocaine good point she looks
like she's made a concerted effort to
practice unhinging her jaw yes exactly
exactly
she looked like she gave Jon Voight that
scar in Anaconda
it was John Voight right
any Letterman looks like the kind of
chick that takes her gum out to blow you
in your car and sticks it on your
dashboard and then when she's done
blowing you she takes the gum off the
desk
can I can I say Mercy I I was I was
I was close I
I hold it like this the whole time
exactly yeah
they're a crowd gathering for you just
like the group that I was with and then
I had to like look at all my friends who
are cooler than me and be like I guess
we have to leave that was so shameful
Now esther you're wrong really because
this is what's good about you no Esther
you're wrong even though you're making
people's life harder we're gonna
encourage you because we think it's
funny no seriously Esther here's what's
good about you
I'm done geez that's it that's it
as these moments where we're not sure
how it's gonna go
that's what's funny about you you like
you can you make the room to a point
where you're like is this
[Laughter]
bad or good what's happening
it's just called not being self-aware I
don't know it's called having like you
know poor impulse control and no manners
and etiquette yeah because when I look
at [ __ ] Muffin Top over here I think
impulse controls
um and by the way I'm fat but I just
want to be clear I also want to wear
jeans like that
can we use this at the top oh no I meant
genetics oh
Okay so
g-e-n-e yeah jeans right and we used to
like attack people and ask them what
they ate for breakfast right you don't
know if they're like are they gonna be
mad at us or not it's like why you're
the annoy you're so annoying
you're you are you are the table at a
comedy cloak of a drunk bachelorette
party that doesn't shut the [ __ ] up
you're walking up to people and being
annoying to them you're not the good
guys here I mean I think you guys know
you're not the good guys let's be
realistic here
every one of these women is the woman in
that [ __ ] uh uh rejoiner that we have
that's like we're going to Montreal yes
exactly
sometimes it works I like to point out
that Italy still sells like red wine and
[ __ ] with Hitler's face on it I know
Hitler's awesome this is not the [ __ ]
country to be acting like a stupid [ __ ]
and now they have female Mussolini from
the News tells us so be very more even
more careful it's amazed I wonder if
she's gonna get the trains to run on
time
well they [ __ ] did in Colorado
it's not a matter of whether or not
they're gonna run on time it's a matter
of where they're going
ooze on them
I'm telling you man she just looks like
she would you know
that type of girl
what do you mean by that no no I'm sorry
man I'm just talking down my ass pests
and they're not for good pests or bad
pass but like that's what was funny
about when you were dancing when Natasha
was singing oh yeah because it was like
week wait Natasha the comedian legaro or
whatever couldn't tell if Natasha liked
it or not and you just kept going and
you were like doing it out of like a
love for what she was doing and it was
but it was like it was the tension in
the moment and then it ended by the way
make leaving the bar strip leaving your
shirt strapped down even though you know
it's down isn't as cute as you think it
is that being the perfect thing okay
thank you I think maybe they're it the
results it's really weird that we're I
know the show's called trash Tuesday so
I understand that's the point but just
in general it's kind of weird like some
of these people these women have just
embraced just being trash like why why
do you want to be trash I don't
understand women have embraced just
being like human garbage that's riddled
with mental illness and STDs yeah adults
are never going to be medium
get kicked out or you have Natasha
Bedingfield in love with you right so
it's like one of the two so she's maybe
right it's like it's always going to be
an extreme outcome so it's worth taking
right I will say I was like it was the
first Memorial I'm like oh we're not in
Kansas anymore like this is a foreign
country like they will ask me to leave
like I'm breaking cultural rules I just
felt really scared like Spirit moved you
yeah yeah I mean My Heart Will Go On in
an Italian like were they mad at your
friend for playing the piano
you are the reason and this is true
because a lot of people go like oh man
when you go to Europe they [ __ ] hate
Americans and I'm thinking to myself
like I don't know man every time I
travel to a different country I always
even a different state I always try to
be respectful of like their customs and
what they do and I understand it's not
where I'm from and it's a normal level
of respect right these are the people
these are the reason why when we go
places other places don't like Americans
because women like you because they
associate the loud broads that are
getting drunk in an Italian restaurant
that's really nice with every [ __ ]
American why do you do that do you have
like any Pride like at all I mean
obviously you don't I mean like I said
your set looks you said looks like a
[ __ ] cartoon set so I'm waiting for
like a tiny baby to walk by smoking a
cigar so you know I get it but like come
on man
I don't know like maybe it wasn't like I
did [ __ ] Brady Bunch set yeah
seriously
try to blame her except nobody has a
decency to die of AIDS I was like she
was playing My Heart Will Go On like I
couldn't control my body yeah you know I
I could understand how you would be
overwhelmed by Emotion by hearing a a
song by a Canadian woman in an old
Italian Villa let them touch the TV let
them touch them yeah a [ __ ] a song
written by a Canadian woman in 1998.
you know that classic Italian [ __ ]
yeah no you're right no one does that
anymore I gotta change my ringtone [ __ ]
well I mean you just have to change it
because you don't want Esther acting a
fool yeah it's an 8-bit version of it
she was right I have cat party oh God
I'm surprised it's not lemon party guy
just had a yeah
[Music]
I think maybe they just don't have to be
here yeah they don't want that this this
show is just like sitting next to three
really really hungover [ __ ] while
they're having mimosas and they're and
their show too
that's true
now Virgie get us some more mimosas yeah
come on you said they were bottomless
you said they were bottomless virgin
that's the only reason we're even here
today
well you guys keep ordering [ __ ]
flights we only have one goddamn bar
[ __ ] by the way by the way
I'm also laughing at the trashiness of
flights of mimosa
why would you have a mimosa fight could
I could I get champagne and put some uh
tang in it I want to try that one okay
we have a flight of mimosas it's the
same champagne but we use Florida's best
on this one and Tropicana on this one
it's just different levels of Pulp
I like to chew my booze in the morning I
want my hair of the dog to actually feel
like I'm chewing hair of a dog
hey she thought it was funny they're
like who's this young girl who's this
tiny baby girl
that was a clip did we get to the banana
party it was a clip no yeah that was a
that wasn't a clip that was a segment
get to the banana part I'm looking for
the banana part merch you don't think
I'm looking for it feverishly
don't they have a banana break
you guys ever find it tough to train
wait you edit oh my God it's a better
help commercial okay